[Musik]
das sich am mittag muss sich heute aus
dem arzttermin das ticket kaufen gehen
mit einem kollegen david marx von dort
fahren dann lernen wir kombinieren und
apathie verfolge ich nicht mit
unsinnigen youtube passieren wird ein
typischer tag in meinem leben wo ich
einfach nicht gerade nach indien nach
projekt mit medienmachern ein neues auto
zusammen stellen weil dort bleibt auf
jeden fall dran
innerhalb der 59
[Musik]
meine jacke vergessen ich glaube schnell
zum und melde ich dann in der stunde
wenn ich die firmen welche folgen mit
den kollegen zu spotten zudem trat sie
heute abend kauft allerdings zurück
gesagt dass dort ergibt und jochen
[Musik]
walter da will ich einmal so eine coole
szene machen wie die schräge vergeblich
aufzuschließen an alle die sich
eventuelle fragen
termin war war einfach kunde
osteopathische der anker kamera das war
einfach nur noch sympathischer also mit
ihren problemen noch hatte vom fußball
und die haben das versucht natürlich
brilliante wetter ihren können meine
damen und herren wir wissen dass ihr
könnt was los war auch mir vielleicht
neu zu konfigurieren
ich habe halt bei meinem auto rettet die
möglichkeit die hupe anpasst
richtig gutenberg-marathon
stellvertreter parkplatz wo soll ich
parkett neue auto passt vielleicht
besser
ich bin ganz sicher dass gelaufen
kollege gesagt hat er hegt keine karten
mehr diesen abend wir sind einfach
hingefahren haben so gewinnen 100 karten
gibt ein auto vorträge schreibt erst mal
dran haben war youtube-chef besser nicht
abonnieren leute okay was ich einsteigen
das ist ja warum sie so blöd weil hier
eine falcon norweger kristian ingolf
löcher danke danke danke dafür ist man
auf jeden fall bis 400 autos
[Musik]
das war super
stinova von autohaus alter forschung
kraft schon abgehoben
doch aktuell von den heads
rechtsgeschäften junge haben legitime
aber sie fällt auch kein unterschied
kurz auch schon wieder freundlich euro
mehr service bereit die richtigen
training im auto zu sehen mit
elektromotor das sind die altersmäßige
chromfelgen heiser das papier die
spalten eindrücken martin und vertrat
dessen neuwagen das sieht man ja auch
und er wird für strache dafür perfekten
zustand sein auto bis zu nehmen ich bin
jetzt die hat gerade den autobauers
mazda 2004 handy nicht was halt wirklich
auch gut finde ist wieder den max auch
gerade von ihm ihre opfer gezogen hat es
läutet ihr dürft ihr wirklich
entscheiden was sein aussicht geholt
rechten weg in die kommentare
wieder hatten tausende know how die
küste falls ihr euch fragt wieso wir
jetzt eigentlich wirklich im quadrat
gemacht und ich wurde uns ja eigentlich
immer so inspiration für ingame videos
deswegen schauen uns jetzt mitunter
sehen und sofort im auto wieder dazu der
tvr ausgesucht
[Musik]
wieder zu hause angekommen bin aber
schon länger zu hause weil die kamera
weiter alle und dann habe ich die
geladenen container hätte ich sogar
schon mal videos geschnitten haben wir
eine neue jeans jacke hier sondern
gekauft schaut man die töpfe wird für
die flotten ich werde jetzt noch pdf
betrachter schon ein bisschen lernen
weil ich auch nicht woche donnerstag um
eine klausur schreiben werde
klar
[Musik]
aufregung
ich bin groß als beifahrer mit ihrem
blog meine damen und herren wie gesagt
ein bisschen feiern wettergefahren
leichter
[Musik]